oh wow manny what have you got there he
made a centerpiece oh that's fantastic
stunning it's garbage
no no no what are you doing it's so
beautiful have the lies jay told me the
truth what did you say i mentioned it
wasn't his best effort he said it was a
swing and a miss why why do you say
these things yeah it's like i married my
mother yeah jay why would you do that
because he's a pritchett
but don't let these negative nellies
drag you down manny because one day you
could have a trillion dollar idea that
the people who supposedly love you most
okay phil
that's it go get the head scratcher the
real head scratcher tm go get it and let
everybody else decide how many trillions
i've cost you way ahead of you
it's what's going on here we are about
to make hat history or as i like to call
it
hatstory
early man had hours and hours to scratch
his weary head but
what about today's busy times
thank you squire great thing about this
you can wear it anywhere
hit it buddy
oh
it's like a thousand tiny angels or line
dancing on my scalp
i
it looks like we got a slight
malfunction and a rear nogginizer
oh shut her down shut her down buddy
it's not working my hair it's got my
hair
okay
fine
i'm fine forgot about that feature it's
an exfoliating scrub buddy can you grab
the safety shears you know what phil
keep it up and i admire you and manny i
know what it's like to stare down
skepticism from a loved one cam not now
why not now it's thanksgiving families
gather issues come up only if you bring
them up it's healthy to get things out
in the open you all know my punkin
chunkin story or do you need a refresher
we've heard it oh several times i love
it with cody and the friends yeah so you
know how it ends but the question is who
here thinks i made that up oh
oh well
doesn't that tell the whole story right
there here we have the skeptics the
dream squashers the pritchetts and here
we have the dreamers the artists the
visionaries sweetie caroline
so we're supposed to believe that you
make a a pumpkin fly across a football
field i can prove it to you right now
let's go to the football yes let's do
this i'd love to end this yeah let's
settle this dreamers versus pritchett
[Applause]
i did not just cook for eight hours so
you people could run off to prove some
asinine point that's only gonna make
half of us feel bad
come on show a little respect
turkey smells great sweetheart is that
turkey
because something smells like chicken
okay let's settle this yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the coolest thing ever
okay i want to film okay i know wait i
want to be in it hey cam are you sure
this is going to work oh god you sound
just like cody
do you think this could launch a human
luke
let's do the pumpkin first okay
they're having fun over there but you
know it's gonna end in tears yeah always
does knock knock who's there physics
thank you who's gonna be able to launch
it i think it should be cam oh no i
think it should be all of us
i don't squash all of phil's dreams just
the ones that are you know potentially
fatal i'm just trying to get the kid
ready for life yes if we didn't do this
to them the world would okay everybody
in final launching positions get ready
to eat some crow
it is not as delicious as it sounds
okay
[Applause]
what happened cam i don't know i i don't
know can we do it again no we only have
one punking and we just chunk it
oh wow well we were right yeah
i'm sorry guys
this usually feels a little better
doesn't it yeah
all right i hate to admit it but when
they put the pumpkin in i was kind of
hoping it would work yeah me too
all right let the gloating begin you
know it was a pretty good try we don't
need your pity let's just get this stuff
cleaned up yeah uh oh well or if if
maybe we um
we launch it from a steeper angle maybe
if you had somebody else you know
helping you pull the thing but we don't
have any more pumpkins that's the easy
part they're on every porch up and down
the block well we can handle that come
on kid
there are dreamers and there are
realists in this world you'd think the
dreamers would find the dreamers and the
realists would find the realist but more
often than not
the opposite is true maybe that's worse
we should launch my centerpiece next it
wasn't that bad your recipe loft was
right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you see the dreamers need the realist to
keep them from soaring too close to the
sun and the realists
well without the dreamers
they might not ever get off the ground
[Music]
[Music]
you